guck mal wie das zu ende geht
bisher haben wir immer irgendwelche am
meisten flugzeug verpasst am haben eine
stunde im gefängnis festgesetzten
gesessen
wir haben ein bisschen zeit ich muss
auch kein flieger kriegen geplant ist
ein interview mit einer tageszeitung
aber ich habe jetzt nur dabei okay ich
sagte ich gehe dann einfach raus gleich
gut ok gesendet wie die lage gut immer
der selbe frage ja es wird sich auch nie
ändern wird sich nie ändern
die lage ist gut album ist draußen die
promotion für mich gut und gleise single
die glaube ich auf marco war die
erfolgreichste single die du je gehabt
hast stimmt das ja auf 12 glaube ich ein
glas und liefert im radio rauf und
runter läuft immer noch aufgrund immer
noch auf und ich höre nicht so viel
radio muss ich sagen happy absolut vor
allem fängt ja immer wieder bei null an
jedes mal wenn du irgendwas neues machst
du das schaffst fängt wieder bei null an
und auch gerade single auskopplung es
ist immer so ein thema wo ich mich ein
bisschen schwierig mit tue weil für mich
ist jeder song auf dem album die single
das ist dann einfach so das erste
zeichen vom album zumal die single ja
nicht unbedingt auch das album
repräsentieren das album auch wieder
sehr verschieden ist von den inhalten
her und es hätte so alles passieren
können
also es war für mich auch so ein
bisschen entweder es funktioniert gut
das funktioniert gar nicht und da gab's
nichts dazwischen bei der single auswahl
die von plattenfirma kam bei mir war
egal was ihr zuerst ausgepowerte egal
weil dir an jedem song wahnsinnig viel
liegt oder übrigens auf den turm
na ja das weiß ich nicht jeder song hat
seine geschichte und jeder song ist für
mich eine single ist es wert
ausgekoppelt zu werden und auch jetzt
bei dem album the doors oder dass wir
auch recht viele songs aus koppeln sich
auch das letzte album kam vor drei
jahren hat sich viel verändert
auch was videodreh ist angelegt war vor
zwei wochen in jamaika und habe im neuen
tagen fünf videos gedreht
es geht einfach heute viel mehr um
content
hier sitzt jetzt auch hier in dem haus
sind
das letzte interview im hotel das
internet hat einfach nochmal
quantensprung gemacht und auch das
musikbusiness hat sich verändert und die
art und weise wie wir im halben promoten
ist auch anders geworden
deswegen gibt es viele single
auskopplung bedauert du den leuten neuen
zeit in dem song remember geht es ja
genau darum früher war das mal die
summer and schnellt manchmal ich habe so
das gefühl ist alles wahnsinnig schnell
geworden gibt von papas stimmen also ich
glaube jede zeit zu sein charme seine
frau nachteile und generell glaube ich
nicht dass es besser oder schlechter
geben sondern nur anders und ich will
einfach mit der zeit gehen natürlich
gibt es sachen in der vergangenheit die
ich irgendwie vermisse und es gibt aber
ganz viele dinge in der gegenwart die
ich einfach sehr zu schätzen weiß auch
ja also wir sind im jahr 2013 und haben
chancen und möglichkeiten wir vorher
auch so nicht hatten und es war vorher
eben nicht wie remember single wo es
genau um dieses thema geht und was sie
gerade angesprochen
diese schnelligkeit es ist schon was so
was ich nicht so gut finden wo ich
einfach merkel irgendwie es ist viel zu
viel zu wichtig und zu schnell und
trotzdem glaube ich aber dass immer auch
eine gegenbewegung irgendwann
stattfindet wenn irgendwas zu viel wird
und ich habe jetzt auch gerade das
gefühl dass wieder so eine sehnsucht und
sein wunsch nach was anderem ist
beziehungsweise nach mehr ausgleich eben
nach langsamkeit nach entschleunigung
nach wahrer kommunikation zwei menschen
treffen sich gucken sich in die augen
im unterhalten sich und nicht irgendwie
kurz angebundene sms verschicken oder e
mails schreiben sondern wirklich sich
zeit zu nehmen und das merke ich bei mir
auch irgendwie diese sich zeit nehmen
ist echt eine herausforderung geworden
wie kriegst du hin mit mit wachsamkeit
ich weiß nicht immerhin versuchte
hinzukriegen
ich muss halt wach sein und ich merke
oft muss es ein bisschen knallen damit
man aufwacht
aber ich glaube schon dass das immer
mehr auch priorität wird auch gerade in
die
zeit die so unglaublich schnell sich
bewegt immer wieder sich zeit zu nehmen
um zu reflektieren um mal durchzuatmen
um gedanken auch mal weiterzuführen um
auch mal nicht zu machen und für mich
ist der absolute luxus dieses morgens
aufzustehen und noch nicht wissen was
ich nachmittags mache das ist für mich
luxus
das kriegst auch ihn selten aber wenn es
dann so ist kann ich es viel mehr
genießen und es hat dadurch eine ganz
andere intensität
also ich weiss es viel mehr zu schätzen
zeit zu haben und auch zeit wirklich im
wertvoll zu verbringen so entstehen in
solchen freiräumen deine songs die songs
entstehen immer anders ich würde jetzt
nicht sagen dass die in solchen freiraum
entstehen aber trotzdem sind dass die
räume wo gedanken weiter geführt werden
und gefühle irgendwie erst mal erkannt
werden können und das ist ja die die
basis und die grundvoraussetzung um was
kreatives machen zu können aber ein song
entsteht an vielen orten und aus vielen
stimmungen heraus und es ist einfach
nicht auf diesen einen moment zu
reduzieren sondern es gibt auch keine
formeln also fernsehen sondern halb so
viele verschiedene stimmungen aus den
songs geschrieben
das kann man nicht auf eine reduzieren
aber warum kriegst oder wie kriegst du
es dann hin dass so ein album macht wo
jeder song single ist weil es ist
wirklich wenn man sich das album anhört
jeder song ist ein unikat und es ist bei
manchen alten hat man das gefühl okay da
ist singe das vielleicht auch noch ein
zweiter gutachter noch ein dritter guter
song
aber dann kann man hören muss man sich
meine musik ist immer subjektiv so und
ich finde es schön dass du dass du
empfindest aber es gibt ja auch leute
die sagen das klingt alles gleich oder
jetzt wiederholt er sich wieder
ich muss es halt fühlen könnten und es
gibt ja so viele kombinationen auch in
der musik natürlich gibt es irgendwo
auch eine wiederholung glaube ich das
lässt sich glaube ich kaum ausschließen
und trotzdem muss ich einfach darauf
achten
das zu tun was ich bock ab und was ich
fühle so und wenn das irgendwie das ist
dann muss es sein
ich mache mir auch gar nicht so viele
gedanken wenn ich musik mache wenn du
das machen würde es bisher schon auf dem
holzweg sondern musik machen ist auch
immer was intuitiv ist ich mache das um
viel wasser und habe gerade irgendwie
einfach diesen druck zu machen und dann
mache ich das erstmal und dann schreibe
ich einen text und dann setze ich mit
meinen jungs zusammen und bequem
zusammen die musik und dann kommt
irgendwann ganz viele schlaue leute die
dann irgendwas da rein interpretieren
und es ist auch immer witzig zu sehen
wie verschiedene musik auch aufgenommen
wird
aber das sind so gedanken irgendwie wo
ich auch mich ertappt
wenn du die zu weit fürst und auch zu
intensiv denkst dann fühlt sich das
irgendwann nicht mehr gesund an
es geht darum die musik ist immer noch
neu so und ist für mich immer noch der
weg mit mir im einklang zu sein
nicht gut zu fühlen wenn ich dann noch
leute damit berühren kann und davon
leben kann dann ist das irgendwie dieses
ding wo ich einfach ja nach 20 jahren
immer noch nicht ganz realisiert habe
dass ich da meinen traum leben und da
bin ich einfach extrem dankbar
ich habe zu diesem traum gefunden wo du
bist ja einfach mit wem wie viel jahren
bist du nach jamaika und 18
wieso wusste und passieren wird oder das
ist nicht mehr was also das ist auch so
damals die zeit die so ein bisschen
schleierhaft ja verschiedene gründe
also ich weiß nicht ob mit 18 bist du
noch ganz anders drauf das heißt ich
glaube du bist ein ganz anderes bild
drin und irgendwie hast du diese diese
junge dynamik und dieses einfach mal
machen und nicht groß nachdenken und
bist überhaupt nicht vorsichtig so ich
merke schon irgendwie man wird
irgendwann noch vorsichtiger aber ich
weiß es nicht also ich war auch immer
sehr im moment ich habe ja nie so weit
vorausgedacht gedacht so was will ich
denn mal werden und ich will mal
irgendwann großer reggae-sänger werden
sondern nicht war immer sehr im moment
und habe einfach das genossen musik zu
machen und habe aber auch glück gehabt
glaube ich mir zum talent gesegnet
worden zu sein
die richtigen leute um mich zu haben das
ist die voraussetzung für erfolg finde
ich immer so ein relatives wort aber um
seinen weg zu finden sagen was man so ja
leute um nicht zu haben sie dich
motivierende dich inspirieren
die kraft geben und das habe ich
irgendwie weiß ich nicht ob ich das
verehrt hat oder ob es einfach und ich
habe immer das gefühl gehabt ich habe
echt glück gehabt mit den menschen hier
um mich herum waren und es ist ja auch
oft auch eine entscheidung zu sagen
ich umgebe mich jetzt in diesem beispiel
und nicht indem und das ist glaube ich
die voraussetzung natürlich irgendwie
diese leidenschaft zur musik auch talent
zur musik aber ihnen das richtige umfeld
und der glaube an wasser und diese vier
dinge zusammen die sorgen dann schon
dafür dass du einfach dann dein weg
findest
aber das ticket also das ticket gekauft
hatte hattest du da so eine idee oder
das kannst du auch nicht auch gerade
jamaika ist ja auch nicht ein land wo du
irgendwo hinfliegen kannst du sagen ich
mach das jetzt soundso er mit seiner
akribischen deutschen konditionierungen
so weil das funktioniert dann aber wenn
man es im rückblick sieht jetzt aus eben
20 jahren rückblick
dann würde man sagen ja okay der hat
sich der wusste dass er das kann dann
ist der dahin geflogen und hat er das
gemacht also als wäre es geplant gewesen
weil es ist ja das ist ja es passt
allianz erdmann unbewusst irgendwie
sieht man vielleicht schon was was man
so gar nicht wahrnimmt
aber ich dachte ich glaube das war
damals diese mischung aus neugier wo
kommt die mucke her die mich so
interessiert und eine abenteuerlust auch
mal irgendwie raus zu kommen was
erzählen zu können
radikalität auch irgendwo
kompromisslosigkeit keine ahnung so ich
habe eben auch nicht so groß nachgedacht
so was soll ich denn da jetzt sagen ich
bin einfach hingeflogen und es gab eine
adresse von einem kumpel von mir namens
vlado der eben diese familie
kennengelernt dann gesagt er will die
besucher freuen sich da kannst du wohnen
und das ist gut so dann bin ich da hin
geflogen und war da auch erstmal so mich
erstmal sehr fehl am platz gefühlt auch
irgendwie wenig verstanden von dem was
die leute da gesagt haben diese zweifel
aber die habe ich auch bis heute
begleitet die habe ich auch jetzt wenn
ich mit dir hier auf dem sofa sitze
immer noch so echt ringsystem war wenn
die vielleicht mal hettich schreiner
werden
das nicht aber so die zweifel in dem was
ich tue und ich glaube alles andere wäre
auch irgendwie ungesunden und natürlich
also zweifel bis zum bestimmten punkt
sind sind gut und auch gesund in
bestimmten punkt wenn sie dann zu
intensiv werden dann wird es irgendwann
nehmen
und das hatte ich auch schon ich mein
einfach so dieses ding das was ich mache
ist es gut so ich finde jetzt nicht dass
ich ein toller sänger bin zum beispiel
also mein range ist sehr limitiert
sondern was findest du ich weiß nicht
ich glaube einfach so ich hab das heißt
ich glaube ich habe einfach bock darauf
dass zu machen
aber es gibt ja so das was die leute
auch glaube ich fühlen deswegen ist es
auch schon so lange jetzt aber ich habe
ja auf den gedanken sich irgendwann das
gefühl aber die boxing gedanken soll
irgendwann finden die leute raus zu sich
eigentlich gar nichts kann und das habe
ich immer schon gehabt und dann gibt es
aber momente wo ich denke so war uns
auch ich bin doch
der entertainer kann auch gute songs
machen aber das schwankt halt immer so
okay aber wenn man das jetzt also für
mich gibt nur zwei sorten von einem werk
es gibt halt sachen die sind okay den
schönen sich andere prima und es gibt so
sachen die sind aus einem guss da gibt
es kein fragezeichen zudem musik fängt
an und du denkst nicht mehr nach sondern
du nimmst du musst kein klassisches werk
seines kann jazz sein es kann jedoch
sein dass generell design und empfindest
du das nicht wenn du deine sachen das ja
das ist so ein ding und ich kann nicht
fallen doch also ich finde ich finde ich
für die dinge schon die ich tue so und
auch die songs die auf dem album sind
das sind alles songs die ich wirklich
fühlen könnte und die ich gehört habe
und ich mich dann ist ja auch immer
schwierig zu objektiv deine eigene musik
zu betrachten aber das waren schon so
dinge auch wenn du dann den paar leuten
die songs vorgespielt wurde merkt
irgendwie da ist einfach eine magie
irgendwie und es wird manche leute
überhaupt nicht berühren und manche
leute wird es aber auf jeden fall
berühren also das habe ich schon sonst
ich hab auch eine gesunde ein gesundes
selbstbewusstsein auch gerade was meine
bühnenshow angeht sondern aber trotzdem
gibt es eben auch zweifel
okay aber diese magie wenn du spürst ist
das dann nicht so ja ich bin genau auf
dem richtigen weg so muss es weitergehen
das dass er das schwankt auch nur eins
in den songs ich denke an superstars ein
knaller seien erst das wird irgendwie
das werden die leute lieben und am
nächsten tag habe ich das ding noch mal
andenkt übernehmen
es kommt auch immer auf der stimmung auf
einen eher du gerade bist aber da ist es
der idealfall wenn wenn wenn du musik
ist und das funktioniert direkt anfangs
nicht an nachzudenken weil es ja
irgendwie einen spirit musik ist ja
nicht irgendwie so ein intellektuelles
kopf ding irgendetwas was man
analysieren kann drückst du in fonds aus
was so rüber worüber du sonst nicht
reden könntest ist das auch so ventil
ist gebiet infrage vielleicht an memory
eigentlich zum beispiel ja ich habe
keine probleme darüber auch zu reden
also ich bin eher ein offener als wir
auch so und ich weiß nicht glaubt also
tillmann gentemann ist schon so eine
person spieler jetzt keine rolle und
auch von den inhalten die was meine
songs angeht das sind auch sachen die
mich auch privat und radien und meine
texte sind jetzt nicht alle
hundertprozentig autobiografisch aber
sie spiegeln schon meine gedanken wieder
und auch meine gefühle so bei memories
zum beispiel dem tod von einem freund
ist das dann für dich also ich das quasi
ein muss so ein song zu machen um das zu
verarbeiten ist überhaupt gar kein muss
musik zu machen aber es ist ein
wunderschöner weg einfach auch besser
klarzukommen in bestimmten situationen
und gerade der song memories war einfach
für mich mehr als therapie so ja ich
dann einfach mit dem sommer saison dann
da war und auch diese magie da war das
war dann irgendwie der moment wo ich
auch viel besser mit der situation
umgehen konnte und wo die trauer dann so
ein bisschen auch in dankbarkeit
umgeschwenkt ist das ist einfach ist
einfach froh war dass dieser mensch
existiert nicht mehr dieses klar diese
lehre die ist immer da auch so aber es
ist einfach ein teil vom leben
ich glaube wir werden ja immer öfter
damit konfrontiert und auch gerade jetzt
in meinem bekanntenkreis oder familie
freundeskreis ist es immer öfter das
irgendwie ein elternteil auf einmal
nicht mehr da ist oder ein freund oder
bekannter habe da jemand aus der familie
das ist einfach ein thema womit wir uns
auch finde ich viel mehr beschäftigen
sollten
der tod ein es wird immer so tabuisiert
in unserer gesellschaft und ich habe
auch mit demjenigen
von den personen handelt immer auch über
den tod gesprochen finde auch dass die
einzige gerechtigkeit ist die es gibt
warum naja weil alle menschen irgendwann
gehen können und müssen und wann diese
highlander vision immer größer werden
ewig leben ich weiß nicht also dadurch
christi auch ein ganz anderes bild aufs
leben und kannst es vielen viel
intensiver leben und auch viel mehr
wertschätzen absolut also ich muss immer
sagen der tod ist ein hervorragender
ratgeber der sagte nämlich dass man
jeden tag auf 7 das beste machen
ich habe irgendwann so ein spruch
gelesen in der wand in berlin der tod
nimmt sich einen tag nach dem anderen
der graf von unheilig der hat mal gesagt
das toll also er sagt das sehr positiv
gesehen er sagt also wir uns genau das
gleiche passiert mir gesagt
dieser freund hat mir etwas hinterlassen
nämlich eine energie um zb um songs zu
machen
der hat mich inspiriert und das ist ein
unglaublich tolles erbe war etwas was
dann doch oder wo etwas positives an
diesem schrecklichen erlebnis dran ist
also im schreckliches erlebnis
natürliches erlebnis sagen was man ja
und es war natürlich auch sehr intensiv
und auch heftig und auch sehr traurig so
aber kann ich absolut nachvollziehen
also es war einfach in dem moment wo
dann diese dieses gelähmt design also
ich hab das in der form noch nie erlebt
dass jemand der mir so nahe steht also
mein bester freund in mit dem ich seit
20 jahren irgendwie durch die welt
getinge bin dann auf einmal nicht mehr
da ist so nennt er auch bei mir gewohnt
hat und der dann immer an dieser couch
waren die dann auf einmal nicht mehr da
ist
diese lehre das war einfach was wo ich
gedacht habe ich komme da nicht drauf
klar also irgendwie und es hat echt lang
gedauert und hab dann auch andere
menschen kennen gelernt so wie ihn und
dann auch irgendwann damit klargekommen
ist und das hat uns auch so ein bisschen
verbunden dass er so auch zur selben
zeit was es ihm passiert sein sohn ist
brutal aus dem leben
morgen in kingston so also das war
einfach was wo denn ich auch sehr gut
kannte 22 jahre alt und es ist ein gang
vor dem raub mord einfach zum opfer
gefallen so kingson ist einfach eine
stadt wo viele morde geschehen das ist
dann so was wenn das so im
bekanntenkreis auf einmal vor der nase
hast dann ist es so bizarr und so
surreal dass man einfach denkt so wie
will man damit klarkommen so das war
einfach was gedacht hat wie macht der
mensch das und die musik war der weg um
irgendwann dinge auch zu verarbeiten und
da einfach zusehen musik ist ich sage
das immer irgendwie und ich will auch
nicht dass das zu floskeln verkommt aber
es ist einfach es ist vielmehr als
entertainment es ist vielmehr als
therapie ist wirklich dieses ding mit
bestimmten situationen klarzukommen und
es ist also das ist mein empfinden es
ist eine brücke und zwar im zeitraum in
alle möglichen absurd wenn man kann das
ja nicht man kann ja nicht objektiv über
musik reden
eigentlich kann man nicht über musik
reden man kann es nicht treffen musik
hören
aber man kann es nur um schreiben man
kann ja ja ich weiß dass immerhin sehe
ich genauso es ist alles etwas
mystisches an das hat irgendwie weiß was
man eben zum glück nicht immer
beschreiben kann und auch musik zu
machen
zum glück gibt's da nicht diese formel
für die musik entsteht
wie geht es gibt es im moment bei tieren
pro musik entsteht ist das wie sondern
moment ja schon es gibt so momente der
klarheit es gibt momente der inspiration
die sehr intensiv sind und ich finde die
kunst ist dann eben so ein moment als
solche zu erkennen
sozusagen auch jetzt gerade was
besonderes da ist irgendwie was so was
raus muss oder eine melodie die da ist
oder eine textzeile oder dieser drang
auf einmal so ich glaube ich kann da
jetzt gerade irgendwie genau das gefühl
in musik manifestieren das ist bei mir
zumindest kein permanenter zustand
sondern es sind wertvolle momente und
muss man als solch einfach begreifen
können wir nicht sein sagt es geht
morgen auch noch so habe ich früher
öfter gehört irgendwie eine gute idee
aber dann so jan erstmalig morgen dann
ist es halt weg so helmut zerlett sagte
mal hier musiker bei bayern hat schmeckt
er sagte mal das ist für mich ein
göttlicher moment dieser moment wo ich
sowas passiert das ist gleich kannst
ganz nicht anders ausdrücken also und
auch wenn ich danach gefragt aber es
stimmt dann glauben und religion und
sondern sich keine ahnung ich glaube
irgendwie an das göttliche so ich glaube
nicht an religion für mich
also religion ist auch was super
persönlich ist mehr hat es nicht so
diesen zugang zum göttlichen gegeben
sondern es kann ein gutes gespräch sein
gänsehaut viel das kann irgendwie guter
song seine reise im einfachen fläche in
der natur also dieses göttliche dieses
gefühl des staunens darum geht sagen was
ein kind immer noch hat zu dieses
staunen was man sich einfach nicht
erklären kann weil wir eben nur ein
kleiner erfolg im universum sind mit
unserem ganzen technologie und unserem
ein fakten zu denken wir sind der
mittelpunkt aber so in dem moment wo man
sich das bewusst macht irgendwie dann
ist auf einmal das ja kann man es auch
nicht verneinen das ist das geld das das
göttliche existiert und das ist es für
mich in das ist religiös und spirituell
und das ist vielleicht auch musik das
ist musik das ist also nicht nur aber es
ist eben das was man alles das was man
nicht erklären kann was die einfach
dieses gefühl gibt sogar dann wünsche
ich dir dass du noch ganz auf dieses
gefühl hast ja ich wünsche nächsten so
weiter ich glaube das geht auch nicht
weg also ich glaube wenn man das mal
irgendwie erfahren hat dann ist es immer
vielen dank
dann kaufte